hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots we're a serious Justice sleeps
we're A Serious XM country right now
sign up to hear Jim and Sam one guy
loves wrestlers the other one just is on
his phone and the other guy loves guy's
married to a woman who's the size of a
wrestler Jim and Sam at Radio oh god
dude they're making a lot of fun wacky
Christmas videos I haven't been Haven
even been watching oh I've been you mean
you mean
Norton yes Norton and his [__] wife is
the greatest
Arc he's in
hell you
think no this is this isn't the right
one hold on let me get the right one
what did you just type [__] into
YouTube because that's going to give a
lot of results no I tried turn into
YouTube and it actually came up Nikki
and Jim okay very Norton Christmas
ah please open those stop making me wait
I got to go to work I wish I had to fart
I love these I love these forced by the
way Jim got probably paid some [__]
internal hundred bucks from [__] Jim
and Sam to come film him and his [__]
husband and then they just do these they
do these wacky like it's it's just like
oh I'm GNA we're g to pretend like
you're holding the stool for this tiny
tree you just picture bu eyy to the
cameraman just being like I'm going to
speak into a [__] like it's a
microphone it's
funny for that all
right they got a little theme and
everything we're uh Somebody went to
Fiverr you know it's so sad like looking
at a place like this which you know not
oh I already know what you're gonna say
because I brought this up on nightwave
but
please well okay couple things I want to
bring up about a play like this number
one you're looking at a place like this
which is like you know not that it's a
badl looking place but like it probably
costs them more than a mill for a place
like this in New York and where it's
located at least at least two at least
very good point at least two right so
you look at that that's depressing right
like that's just depressing but also all
like the [__] sign celebs on the wall
like he's a child like H right not only
that but can I bring this up sure you're
talking about all right let's call it a
mil million five right you pay for a
place like this it's so small more they
film in there it's so tiny for what you
get and I'm like like dude I would just
go live in Florida you'd have a [__]
you would have a house that looks like
the rumble headquarters for the same
money yeah you know what I mean with a
boat
dock well I'm sure there's docking that
goes on here
too today I'm wearing red red red red
shoes are from Jeffrey Campo have to get
nails done maybe that's a video shoes
are by Jeffrey Campo but they're still
on the foot of a
dude you know what I mean like uh
actually you know Vanessa Williams had
size 12 feet yeah you know what else she
had a [__] so I mean you know so I
figured this out too Jim like 10 years
ago was talking about buying large shoes
for a Scandinavian person like like some
training he was dating and it was all
like alluded to on the air but there
were all these little hints this is the
training yeah it has to
be it's definitely this [__] says in
one of the videos like I've been with
Jim for a very long time and I'm like
this is the same [__] you're just
doing your own opening video we're going
to set the tree up we I we had one last
year we just threw it out there's no
room to store it there they are again
price there's no room do you hear what
he just said for for a m for $1 and5
million dollar plus you can't have
restore a Christmas tree I really value
Christmas so he married
it especially being Nordic Christmas
Christmas is very important Roy lives
Roy lives in a house that's 20% the
value of Jim's place and he could put a
Christmas tree if you just put it in the
garage yeah or the shed I have so many
places I can put the Christmas tree or
the attic or like one of the extra rooms
yeah I got places for it one of the
various closets is you want this poster
gone it's one of the best comedy albums
of all time and this is a rare post yeah
you just say that cuz you just want you
just like it's took gives you a reason
to say [__] poster but for the
Christmas videos she wants it to be down
it's going to go back up I just want it
to be more cozy I'll put us something
else to
oh here's the thing right I would be
furious to move my [__] off my walls for
a like an actual woman right and to do
it for you know what I mean this and to
do it for a dude
to do it for your male roommate yeah so
your so your chick with dick roommate
could have a nice Christmas photo [__]
you yeah and who's she going to send it
to she does have parents it's true none
that talk to her anyway hello this was a
cam girl that he was like somebody
brought it up in the chat when I figured
out who this was other people that were
OA fans started like it's knocking like
Memories loose and they mentioned too
this was a cam chick like a [__] cam
girl that he was like one of the top
donors for right she used to call them
their her princes and poster to replace
the BR prior all right but that's not
what someone says yall cook in gym in
here yeah we do all the time we're doing
in the chat corrected me you're right
cam guy not girl you're right you're
right you're
[Music]
right I'll hang this so so it's more
christmy so you like here's What's
Happening Here you ready there's a lot
of things Jim Jim loves Aussie right we
all know that Jim loves Aussie Osborne
that's one of his [__] things that he
loves he didn't love his books though no
but he loved Aussie remember no remember
when he left his book sitting on the
table oh
yeah but so he loved Aussie whatever and
this and and he also probably watched
Aussie's reality TV show and that's what
he wants to do he wants to do like his
own [__] version of that I don't know
why because this genre like nobody cares
about it anymore but like how half of
the jokes are going to be oh my god look
how big our hands are it's going to be
they're going to be [__] jokes but at
the end of the day you're still having
sex with it with it right yeah that's
what I was saying on nightwave so this
it's not gonna the woke crowd's not
going to like it because you're making
[__] jokes and you're like you're
making a a [__] joke of it yeah and
then like normies aren't gonna watch it
because you're [__] a dude yeah easy
sloth just donated and said dude at
least pick a [__] with with who's tiny
with big tits not a goddamn Viking
it's true I mean like it's not he's not
even dating a trap he's dating a [__]
yeah it's not even a Blair white [__]
it's like a [__] dude in a wig
yeah your butt crack I your box are so
low they can fat they fall that's not
going to fit there go in the back and
help me guide it for Pete's sake be a
help not a hindrance what do I do Jim
I'm wearing cashmere so what this is not
good you're either going to so now
they're doing a
fake yeah this old thing everything they
do every activity they engage in in this
is like a all right get the camera we're
going to do a Tre is any of it ever
funny no no no no no no it's Jim Norton
yes funny in 10 years hurt your foot can
you just let it go can you just stop the
last time Jim Norton was funny was when
he was yelling at Dragon wagon Jesus
Christ Let It Go no this is not going to
work get me a fork I'll show you a trick
that's hilarious Rabbi cash said Jim
could have chose a Blair white type
instead he chooses Thanos yeah you need
to hire someone for this next time
Thanos [__] what did you do Ryan Quinn
the check is calling him Ivar the
dickas can you just stop right
now just just stop what supposed to be
like that it's not why are you doing
this ere exaggerating [__] Jim come
on man so he can show off his gold
Fork the
guys no come
on oh is that awesome fantastic that's
the glitter poster I hate it I [__]
hate it come on it's the kiss glitter
poster makes you look like a [__] what
it's a holidays oh my God you imagine
[__] what yeah that's what Mak like a
f what do you want me to do make me
coffee Jim does give me a credit card
and an Li so I will make you a coffee
thank you
sweetie he
he at one point he was he was dating
Chelsea Peretti remember that oh my God
yes I just want to comp I just I just
want to compare like Jim has absolutely
dated some pretty hot [__]
right and to go from
that Jen kedy yeah Jen carmed was goodl
looking it's [__] hot in here Nick
Jesus I made your coffee it's how is it
77° in the house it's not that warm it's
70 no it's 82 oh my God just don't like
the same temperature will you get over
it well the pope would bless your
marriage I mean so that's
cool you really married a dude yeah I
thought it was a bit it's not a bit well
it is a is the biggest one I cling to
relevance wait should we put down the
tree skirt first hold on the [__]
thing's coming out already is this right
okay not the first time something's come
out of a skirt with Jim huh ow oh ow I
don't lift my shirt my fat back [__]
FR real no don't put that on yet I have
to oh really yeah I'm really getting
joyful little spiral thing or something
wow you really thought you could make
squeeze a 10-minute video out of this
boring [__] [__] holy [__] yeah my
God if you and Marie made a video of you
putting up the tree and it was this long
I'd be like what are you doing I
wouldn't do that anyway but yeah like
what are you
doing oh
[__]